الحب هو المغفره التي لا نهايه
والعطاء الذي يصبح عاده اما علميا فهناك
ما يعرف بهرمون الحب اقصيتين المسؤول عن
الترابط الاجتماعي بين البشر وتوطيه
العلاقات بين الازواج والابناء والاسر لكن
دراسه جديده اجريت في جامعه كاليفورنيا
قررت تحدي تلك الثوابت والدراسات التي
اجريت على مدى عقود بعدما كشفت نتائجها ان
في فئران براري معدله جينيا استطاعت تكوين
علاقات طويله الامد مع شريك واحد حتى بعد
نزع مستقبلات اوكسيتوسين تمكنت من
الاعتناء بالصغارها بشكل طبيعي
ان المستقبلات لا تزداد تلعب دورا مهما في
نمو الصغار حيث واجهت صعوبه في البقاء على
قيد الحياه حتى
الصين او هرمون الحب قد يكون احد اطراف
معادله الحب والترابط لانساني
[موسيقى]